I will try and find the smaller one ken
Bening is the co-owner of the UK's only
caviar maker he likes to get up close
and personal with the products yes here
in Devon southwest England he helps grow
fish which produce the delicacy known as
black gold this is a mature sturgeon and
it's Ken's meal ticket that belly is a
fluffer caviar Ken's been selling caviar
for over a decade but it was a mixture
of luck and good fortune that he met
ornamental fish growers the camera-shy
George Noble here and his father to
start a farm like this would cost a lot
of money so we were lucky to meet them
the unlikely pairing of a London caviar
man and the Devon fish farmers worked
Exmoor caviar was born but this is no
flash-in-the-pan success story it takes
8 to 10 years to grow these sturgeons so
this is going to take time this is the
small and immaculately clean room that's
used to harvest the caviar from sturgeon
the fish eggs are cut out washed salted
and that's about it a quick process
that's we call zucchini for a food which
will put a serious hole in your wallet
1,500 pounds the European caviar market
is closely guarded run by a select few
manufacturers when Ken and his team
announced they were going to make the
delicacy in the UK it ruffled feathers I
once called a fly-by-night we've been
called a lot worse ken says Exmoor was
accused of breaching production
standards but officials have found no
faults and his caviar is favored by some
of the UK's top chefs you've got a
British caviar it's produced with corner
sea salt it's farmed here in Devon you
know it's a unique product and chefs
like you need products
Angus Bennett Bloomberg